[Musique]
dit on est obligé d'aller dans un trou
paumé comme ça et on dira décor deux
fils ben voila je le sentais ya pas de
réseau open web 0 bord j'ai fait une
petite angoisse mais ça va mieux ça dit
qu'elle j'ai tout pour l'angoissé le
casting pour un film à hollywood mec
jaloux
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tout seul je les ai vus j'ai des gros
scores
les grands yeux
est ce que quelqu un mouchoir ta gueule
montrez-moi votre côté pienaar
[Musique]
alors quelle est la cible mammifère aux
êtres humains ont la pire soirée de
toutes mains
bon
pour m
coffret wahaha bravo à toute l'équipe
c'était super y'avait pas de monstre
c'était une mise en scène en question il
pas longtemps j'ai eu un rôle mais
c'était
[ __ ] tu pars quel bar tu parles